...et je crois que ça me va pas parce que je suis un peu heu ...
...enfin, j'ai des hanches, et tout, donc c'est...
C'est pas idéal, tu vois...
C'est pas... c'est pas fou, tu vois.
Dans tous les cas, je voulais te dire, c'est vraiment cool de passer du temps avec toi.
Ouais, je suis contente, je trouve que ça se passe super bien.
D'ailleurs, si tu veux passer à la maison tout à l'heure
ouais ouais
non, enfin SI tu veux...Ya pas de...
non non, bien sûr, pardon.
écoute euh...On s'entend vraiment bien tous les deux alors je pense que je peux être honnête
Bien sûr vas-y
Je voudrais pas te gêner...
Tu rigoles! T'inquiètes ça va!
dis moi!
J'ai deux bites
Lola?
ça va?
ça va et toi?
Je comprendrais que tu sois choquée
Par tes deux bites?
oui...
Nonnnnn bah ça va, on est en 2016, j'suis vraiment pas quelqu'un de fermé d'esprit, euh non non !
t'as...t'as deux bites, c'est...genial...
ça reste une malformation quand même.
oui, bien sûr!
bien sûr.
et je te trouve hyper courageux.
Parce qu'en plus, j'imagine que l'état fait pas grand chose pour les gens comme vous donc euh....
Alors les "gens comme moi" supportent très bien. Maintenant c'est sûr qu'y a une vraie discrimination à l'embauche
personne ne parle de nous dans les medias,... Les urinoirs sont super mal foutus..
-Lola?
-mmh?
Pardon, j'étais en train de réfléchir en fait à quel point je trouvais ça cool en fait
que tu me fasses ASSEZ confiance, pour me DIRE que CARREMENT,
t'as deux...deux bites quoi....
c'est...c'est normal
et du coup j'peux te poser une question?
est-ce que tu...(pardon pour l'expression)
"bande avec les deux?"
oui!
ouahhhhhhh
deux fois plus de plaisirs!
non!
..parce qu'en l'occurence, j'ai deux très petits pénis
-d'accord.
celui de gauche est circoncis, celui de droite devient bleu quand l'été arrive.
à condition qu'il fasse 20°C
pour ça que je passe l'été en bretagne. Voilà, comme ça tu sais tout.
mmh j'suis contente.Je voulais pas forcément tout, TOUT savoir mais bon.
-ok donc on peut changer de sujet?
-bien sûr!
excuse moi.
et...du coup t'es un peu parti cet été?
ouais, chez mes parents, près de Vannes
ah ok.Et t'as combien de testicules du coup?
PUTAINNNNN !
Bon écoutes je vais y aller.
Nan mais pardon. J'm'en fous que t'aies 2 bites, 16 couilles ou je sais pas quoi.Moi ça me gène pas
Excusez - moi,
Monsieur, nous avons entendu que vous souffriez d'un sérieux handicap,
la maison tient donc à vous offrir votre repas pour saluer votre courage
Oh putain...
Mais reste , reviens, attends
c'est pas la taille, ni le nombre ni la couleur qui importe
Moi je suis pas gênée, je te jure !
C'est moi qui suis gêné, CONNASSE !
Ah d'accord !
Bon, les insultes, très bien
Moi j'ai vraiment, vraiment pas de chatte en fait
Si, j'ai une chatte , enfin j'en possède une, j'ai pas de..comment..
de chance quoi
Et vous faites ça souvent ?
De quoi? attendre le bus ?
ha, nan, je veux dire, "vous attendez souvent personne ?"